bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce tout nouveau webinaire on arrive
au numéro 20 déjà est donc aujourd'hui
nous allons poursuivre ce que nous avons
commencé maintenant depuis trois séances
avoir exploré un exemple concret de
trajectoire de son donc j'espère que
vous allez bien on va encore avoir
je pense deux ou trois séances avec
celle d'aujourd'hui pour pour finaliser
cet exemple qui est une occasion de voir
un comment à partir des mêmes jeux de
données on peut arriver à faire
plusieurs choses avant de refaire un
petit résumé de la semaine dernière ce
que je vous propose déjà
vous l'avez vu là j'ai réouvert air
studio je suis reparti de mon projet un
de la semaine dernière nous avons ici
notre cliché v3 comme à chaque fois je
vais faire une je vais l'enregistrer
sous pour avoir une nouvelle version
donc ces vases trajectoire les 4 et puis
pour être sûr que je remets meurent mais
dont l'état de l'analyse de la semaine
dernière je vais régler culte et
l'ensemble de l'analyse pour ça tout
simplement aller sur cessions donc
du côté exécute ça va me permettre de
refaire un petit point donc la semaine
dernière nous avions fait une analyse de
séquences pour essayer d'identifier des
des profils de trajectoire on avait tout
d'abord commencé avec une analyse de
séquences sur l'ensemble de notre
fichier mais nous l'avions vu sa poser
un petit problème technique puisque et
bien les catégories qui émergeait
c'était en avant en premier lieu des
trajectoires courtes et des trajectoires
long puisque nous avions des délais
d'observation très différent d'un
individu à l'autre
or c'est un des effets de l'optimum
matching c'est que lorsque l'on calcule
la distance entre deux séquences de
longueur très différentes
on a forcément une distance et les et
donc du coup la classification
hiérarchique sur notre matrice distance
a tendance à regrouper les distances
courtes les séquences courtes entre
elles et les séquences longues entre
elles
or donc à présent la durée de la
séquence est avant tout un effet du
d'observation puisqu'on a des individus
qu'on observait plus ou moins longtemps
plus qu une conséquence du phénomène
étudié et c'est pour ça du coup que nous
avions refait dans un deuxième temps une
analyse de séquences mais limitée aux
individus observés au moins 18 mois et
ne prenons en compte que les dix
premiers mois d'observation à partir
donc si je reviens la priorité que c'est
terminé donc si je reviens insurers
partie de ces cons sur 18 mois
1 nous avions obtenu vous avez ici le de
rendre au gramme sur la gauche il où tu
habites séquence sur la droite
nous avions exploré comment découper en
plusieurs en plusieurs groupes et nous
avions choisi d'avoir un découpage en de
découper l'ensemble en quatre classes et
nous avions abordé le paquet de vérité
de clusters qui a un paquet ce jeu
développé par rem équipe de genève qui a
développé le package grameen
qui fournit un certain nombre
d'améliorations et notamment nous avons
utilisé l'algorithme pam qui se fait au
niveau des mets de it's pour essayer
d'améliorer notre typologie donc nous
avions obtenu deux classifications une
première que nous avions appelée type o
c à h qui était basée sur la
classification ascendante hiérarchique
la deuxième
toujours en 4k ce que nous avions fait
en repartant de l'arbre mais avec un
critère de de partitionnement plus
global avec l'algorithme a donc ici
calculé avec la fonction fc camedo id
donc on a une deuxième typologie et nous
avions fait en toute fin de session
je le montre la un graphique un tapis de
séquences de nos quatre de nos quatre
typologies et donc nous avions une
typologie en quatre groupes les rapides
des personnes qui sont rentrées dans les
soins assez rapidement des personnes qui
sont rentrées dans les soins en dans les
18 mois mais qu'ont mis plus de temps
qu'ils sont entrain de soi plutôt entre
6 mois et 12 mois et qui ont atteint du
coup une charge virale contrôlée qui est
la couleur en en bleu foncé ce qu'on
appelait les et n'aboutisse vers des
personnes qui sont rentrées en soins et
qui n'ont pas initié de traitement ou
alors qu'ils n'ont initie qu'un certain
temps pions arrêté par exemple ici oui
ce trait bleu foncé ça veut dire
quelqu'un sous traitement et qui est
arrêté de prendre le traitement bout de
trois mois
et puis enfin une dernière catégorie
qu'on appelait les orcs soins qui sont
les personnes qui ne sont pas du tout
rentrer en soins ou alors qu'ils sont
rentrés mais n'y sont pas sortis à noter
un ça c'est un des effets des
classifications c'est parfois on a des
individus un petit peu atypiques comme
si non qui sont pas toujours cassé au
bon endroit
nous avons ici des personnes pour
commencer un traitement et qui vont
atteindre une charge égard à contrôler
mais très très tardivement alors cela on
pourrait peut-être plutôt les voir comme
des super lent il se trouve que comme
ils ont été hors soins pour une très
grande période ils sont plus proches en
terme de distance d or sont un peu
d'élan
mais voilà on a donc ses petits
individus
maintenant que nous avons créé une
typologie en cas de classes dont pour
rappel nous avions créé un objet qu'on à
pieds larges m18 donc l'objet large m 18
ans et un bon vin seul seul regardez
donc il à 1317 observations de 25
variable donc large avec 18,1 c'est le
le jeu de données avec une ligne à un
individu son statut dans l'est sont en
cours des 18 premiers mois et du coup de
dents à nous avions aux stocks et du
coup notre type au ch et notre type au
pam
nous avions même recoder type au pam en
un facteur qu'on appelait groupe hors
soins rapides inaboutie lent et puis
donc nous avions un rang que nous avions
calculé à partir de de la variable cmd à
200 escape pour avoir juste un ordre
dans notre dans notre graphique on a
donc ici à nos quatre catégories est
généralement une fois qu'on a quatre
catégories ce que l'on souhaiterait ça
serait pouvoir décrire un petit peu
mieux nos catégories et voir notamment
les facteurs associés à l'appartenance à
chaque groupe
donc aujourd'hui nous allons aborder
cette étape de l'analyse donc les
facteurs associés à chaque groupe
alors pour rappel dans notre jeu de
données initiales quel objet qu'est la
trajectoire is je ne remets à l'écran
pour qu'on puisse se souvenir de ce fils
d'officier données initiales donc là
pour rappel quatre projecteurs is il y
construit avec une ligne par mois et par
individu
mais on dispose d'un certain nombre
d'informations sur les individus et plus
spécifiquement selon selon ce que l'on a
c'est le sexe des individus
le groupe d'âge le niveau d'éducation et
le niveau de richesse ainsi que la
distance à la clinique la plus proche
aujourd'hui on va regarder simplement
les caractéristiques sociodémographiques
principal donc on va juste regarder sexe
âge et éducation mais ce qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui on pourrait l'étendre en
incluant le niveau de richesse et la
distance à la clinique
on voit ici à l'écran à ses côtés sous
forme de chiffres et donc pour y voir de
manière peu plus précise je peux
toujours un refaire un look fort
j'applique acquaert urgent hectos reese
et on est là où on le voit donc le sexe
un seco des sous la forme d'une variable
des belles plus lbl donc ça veut dire
doble plus label death est donc un
lecteur numérique labellisé avec les
codes hommes et femmes caudéran 0 1
l'âge est en fait qu d123 pour ses 29
ans 30 59 ans 60 ans et plus 1 donc on
est aussi en catégorielles et le niveau
d'éducation est codé sous trois niveaux
primaire secondaire ou supérieur
donc on va on va regarder du coup
comment ces trois variables la sexe âge
et éducation sont associés ou non à nos
différentes anneaux variable à nos
catégories alors qu'il faut retenir
c'est que pour rappel le fichier 4
projecteurs is possède une ligne par
individu et par mois et les différentes
variables sociodémographiques qui sont
enseignées peuvent varier au cours du
temps alors autant le sexe va être une
variable qui va être fixes mais si
jamais quelqu'un avait 29 ans début du
suivi et on a 30 plus loin dans suivi
sont la variable âge va changer d'un
fichier 4 lectrices donc ça va être une
variable dépendante du temps d'en cas
présent nous une analyse de trajectoire
donc on n'a plus qu'une seule
trajectoire par individu donc il va nous
falloir ces variables là sur un seul
point de temps et donc ce qu'on va faire
on va rajouter les variables
sociodémographiques dans fichiers large
m18
mais ce que je vais faire je vais
récupérer du coup les données au début
du suivi il me faut qu'une seule valeur
par individu donc ce que je vais
comparer ces les caractéristiques
sociodémographiques au début de suivi
c'est à dire au moins 0 donc ce que je
veux je vais donc prendre largement 18
auquel je vais rajouter des données
alors n'oubliez pas le nombre
d'individus n'est pas le même dans large
m18 que dans quatre secteurs ic/i à
trajectory contient tous les individus
que l'on observé alors que dans large et
18 jeunes et que les individus observés
au moins 18 mois on va donc passer pour
rajouter des informations d'un fichier
plus large un fichier plus restreint
passer par un left john
pour rappel quand on fusionne avec un
legs john on va rajouter des
informations à toutes les variables du
fichier de gauche mais s'il ya des
individus à des observations qui
correspond à des individus dans le
fichier de droite qui ne sont pas dans
le fichier de gauche
on va tout simplement les ignorer or ce
que je veux c'est ne pas changer le
nombre d'observations dans leurs gènes
donc ce que je vais faire j'ai fait un
left jaune et maintenant il faut que
j'explique qu'est ce que je veux
récupérer mois ce qui va m'intéresser
c'est de récupérer uniquement les
données à m 0 donc je vais partir de kia
trajectory je les applique
filter pour sélectionner des lignes
membre égal zéro dont j'ai gardé
uniquement les observations pour
premiers mois comme mon fichier est
totalement propre
j'aurais eu du coup une seule ligne par
individu parce que chaque individu n'ai
vu qu'une seule fois à m 0 et puis je ne
vais pas récupérer toutes les variables
mais je veux seulement récupériez
certaines variables
donc je vais sélectionner idée qui est
l'identifiant des femmes et qui est
important puisque cela maria qui va me
permettre de fusionner de bien retrouver
les bonnes personnes
le sexe l'âge le niveau d'éducation donc
juste pour vous montrer ainsi je prends
juste morceau de code là et que je les
exécute
dans ce morceau de code là va me
permettre de récupérer un fichier de
2009 129 l'insee le nombre de personnes
que j'ai dans mon fichier avec
uniquement
du coup les données à m 0 et les
variables sexe âge et éducation donc
c'est ça que je vais rajouter officier
largement 18 mai dans mon livre jaune
il faut aussi que je précise hi égalité
pour indiquer qu'elle est la variable
qui va servir à fusionner les deux
fichiers dans l'argile 18 on a également
la variable idée je vous le rappelle on
l'a conservée tout au long du parc
tout au long du processus précédent et
c'est important toujours de conserver
identifiant des individus et donc par
cet identifiant je suis sûr d'associer
les bonnes valeurs aux bonnes personnes
bien sûr tout ça il faut que je pense à
se regarder donc tout ça ça va revenir
en place et large m18
donc si j'exécute cette portion de code
j'ai mis à jour m large m18 et si je
regarde large m18
j'ai maintenant mes nouvelles variables
qui sont associés
d'observation toujours 2317 comme on est
passé par l'inf châu les individus qu'il
y avait dans quelle trajectoire is mais
qui ne sont pas dans l'argent 18 ont été
ignorés au moment de la fusion
alors première chose à faire très
classiquement on va faire un tableau
croisé et on l'a vu s'il ya un package
qui est vraiment utile pour faire des
tableaux croisés c'est package dj
sunnery donc on va tout simplement
chargé qui tissent mallery en mémoire
nous avons par
de larges m18 je vais pas je veux pas
garder toutes les variables dans mon
tableau ce que je vais avoir besoin
c'est uniquement de comparer en fonction
du groupe du sexe de l'âge et
d'éducation donc je vais rajouter un
select
donc je veux le groupe âge sexe
d'éducation et je vais faire tout
simplement tibi elle alors premiers
éléments on voit que la variable agen
est l'écho dès aujourd'hui comme un
facteur labellisé donc ici j'ai un
message
kim hee kim est transmis par dix navires
pour rappel les variables avec la belle
les vecteurs utilisés sont des
structures intermédiaires etc au niveau
de l'analyse on est censé les passé sont
en valeur numérique soit en valeur sont
un facteur alors la fonction tout factor
du package abed permet de convertir
toutes les variables qui sont labellisés
en facteurs non si je fais bonjour je
vous montre si je monte donc large et
mme 18
je manque la balle de sexe donc on a des
chiffres 1 2 labellisés si je passe à
fonction tout factor du package label à
son nom
là elle est transformée en un facteur
d'accord avec les modalités hommes
femmes qui correspondent aux étiquettes
que j'avais mis ce qu'il faut retenir
c'est que parfois vous pouvez aussi
avoir une variable qui n'a pas toujours
la ds qui est partout où je vais prendre
un exemple si je fais x le vecteur 1 1 2
3 1 2 maintenant je l'aï donnée
étiquette dont je veux dire que value la
besoin la belle hausse de x je vais
donner une étiquette à la valeur je veux
dire oui légal un égal deux ans si je
vous présente x1 il vaut 1 1 2 3 1 2
mais j'étais tic est unique manche sur
la valeur une la valeur 2 si je fais
tout factor de x ça va me le transformer
en un facteur
et si jamais il ya des valeurs observées
qui n'ont pas d'étiquette
à ce moment là on va là on a crié un
niveau qu'on a appelé trois pour palper
à tout facteur a aussi une option qui
est drop news
[Musique]
donkey et nos labels tout et n'a d'égal
choo et là ça voudrait dire que si
jamais j'ai une valeur qui n'a pas
d'étiquette
à ce moment là je la transforme en l1 et
vous avez pas mal d'autres options avec
tout facteur l'autre variable qu'on peut
l'autre fonction qu'on peut utiliser
elle nous est rappelé ici un an le
message qu'ils tissent l'abri 1
on nous parle de tout facteur anne
labelle et nos classes une classe ça
permet de retirer une classe spécifique
on a mis sur un objet et si je fais une
place de x je vais lui retirer sa classe
de vecteurs labellisé ça va devenir un
simple vecteur numérique 1 si vous
regardez une classe 2 x je lui fais
classe ce n'est plus un vecteur est visé
c'est une simple valeur numérique les
étiquettes sont encore associés à
l'objet mais peu importe ça va être une
simple valeur numérique et si j'applique
une classe ax à ce moment là quand je
l'intérêt dans un modèle ou dans une
analyse ou hadji qui se marie ça sera
détectée comme une variable continu et
non comme une variable catégorielles
alors tout facteur peut s'appliquer
aussi un tableau dans sa globalité
et puis parfois on peut aussi avoir
quelque chose d'un peu plus strict qui
est la fonction e label thx un label en
fait c'est une sorte de raccourci qui va
vérifier si toutes les valeurs observées
ont une étiquette associés si toutes les
variables par valeurs observées ont une
étiquette ont converti en facteurs sinon
on passe en classe donc un exemple si le
fait un label de 2 x comme x 1 à des
étiquettes que sur 1 et 2 mais qui est
un chiffre 3 qui traîne à ce moment là
ce n'est pas converti en facteur s'est
converti en recteur numérique
si l inverse je rajoutais donc avec
valve label cette fois ci au singulier
x3
je rajoutais une valeur nsp maintenant
j'ai un objet x1 qui a des valeurs 1 2 3
et tout on a une étiquette unl à belz 2x
sera converti en facteur puisque toutes
les valeurs observées ont bien une
étiquette associe est donc un label dont
on peut l'appliquer à un tableau dans sa
globalité
ça permet d'avoir du coup rapidement une
règle simple si on est éthique est
partout on convertit en factor simon des
étiquettes ça repasse en un vecteur
numérique et si on a bien codé tous les
éléments donc là pour faire mon analyse
moi ce que je veux ce sont des
étiquettes je passais kolda donc je vais
je vais juste appliqué unl à belz avant
plaimont tibi elle se marie et à ce
moment là les variables âge sexe
éducation comme elles ont toutes les
étiquettes pour toutes leurs valeurs
observées vont être convertis en facteur
je ré exécute ceci voyez j'ai la
variable groupe rapide lent inaboutie
hors soins la variable âge alors ce
petit symbole là ça veut dire que ageeci
et est codé à une étiquette avec un
accent sa fiche mal dans la prévision
mais quand on génère le rapport en
entier les accents sont correctement
affichés ensuite juste à savoir c'est
dans la prévision à studio qu'on a un
petit souci et on voit que sexe a été
correctement affichés ainsi que le
niveau d'éducation
là encore une fois l'accent dans la
prévisualisation sa fiche mal mais quand
on va générer notre rapport avec 8 à la
fin ultra correctement affichés en
anglais il n'y a pas trop souci puisque
on ne dit jamais d'accent alors
maintenant qu'on a fait ça j'ai du coup
mon tableau moi ce qui m'intéresse et
crème de pouvoir les comparer en
fonction des groupes
donc pour faire un tableau croisé on a
juste ajouté
pai égale groupe et l'âge obtient
directement un tableau croisé à retenir
regardé par défaut les pourcentages qui
sont affichés lorsqu'on fait un bail
avec t-bills mairie sont les
pourcentages en colonnes alors non ça
nous va assez bien on veut décrire les
rapides et on voit que celle et rapide
26 % des personnes sondées hommes et que
dans les soins ses 45% des personnes qui
sont des hommes 1 mais encore une fois
n'oubliez pas de penser éventuellement
si vous voulez plutôt affiché des
pourcentages en ligne des pourcentages
en colonne parce que le narratif la
manière de présenter vos résultats sera
un petit peu différente
on peut très facilement avoir des tests
de comparaison si je rajoute adpi ça va
me rajouter une colonne avec un test de
comparaison là on voit que toutes les
variables sont fortement significative
et j'ai une petite note le petit neveu
qui me dit que par défaut le test était
calculé c'est
ôter du kid 2 personnes sachant que ce
que fait j'ai tissé mal rien il va
détecter si vos variables sont
numériques ou compte catégorielles et va
choisir un test en fonction ici vous
souhaitez personnaliser l'hôtesse est
toujours possible un auquel cas je vous
renvoie à la fonction à l'aide de la
fonction ap donc nous crp impliqués un
objet tibial se marient et vous avez ici
une valeur test qui permet d'indiquer
les différentes est ce que l'on peut
faire à et vous avez là une aide qui
vous précise les différents types de
tests qui sont utilisés façon qu'en
règle générale par défaut un petit belge
bailly va vous sortir le test le plus
courant est le plus fréquent dans la
situation qui vous concerne
et puis ça peut être aussi intéressant
d'avoir une colonne total à avoir la
partition global ce qu'on peut faire
avec agde aux rôles par défaut ça vous
le mets au tout début du tableau et si
on veut à la fin on va juste rajouté
last égard zhu et en faisant ceci on
habille
au total alors là on ad'abord ajouté la
paix valeur puis la colonne total sachez
que résultats pour être un petit peu
différent si on rajoute d'abord la
colonne total puis qu'on ajoute la
colonne des pédaleurs ces jeux
l'ordre des colonnes du coût sera un
petit peu différent pour rappel il est
aussi possible de franciser le tableau
notamment en ayant des virgules
comme séparateur ici de com comme
séparateur dons pour franciser
l'ensemble je vais faire thème
guy thys marie longue watch
je vais indiquer que je veux la langue
française mais je veux aussi indiqué que
mon séparateur de décimales ça soit la
virgule et que le séparateur de milliers
soit l'espace en faisant ça un génie
tableau et voyez le séparateur décimales
a été mis à jour depuis du coup et bien
maintenant j'ai fait va leur lieu de
paix value totale du dos aux rôles et si
vous regardez en bas du tableau le nom
du têt a également été traduits test du
kit d'indépendance au dernier point
voyez que par défaut en fait il ya un
arrondi sur les pourcentages 1 à l'aller
pourcentage au-dessus de 10% sont
arrondis à l'unité et en dessous soit on
n'y avait qu'une seule décimales si je
veux pouvoir contrôler un petit peu plus
mais à mais arrondi
je vais du coup lui passer mon nombre de
décimales or je vais garder 0 décimales
pour les premières valeurs qui sont les
les les effectifs et pour les
pourcentages veut dire une décimale
sauf qu'en fait il faut le préciser pour
quel type de variables j'ai fait quelque
chose qui était pas preuve je meurs je
m'excuse on va reprendre
donc il faut que j'indique pour quel
type de variables et donc là c'est pour
les variables catégorielles donc pour
les balades catégorielles qui sont
représentés sous la forme effective pour
101 g indique que le premier chiffre
doit être arrondis pas avec ce genre
décimales le deuxième avec une
l'eau et voyez maintenant mon tableau et
uniformiser sur monde dessine une autre
manière de représenter ces données là de
manière peut-être plus visible c'est
c'est de faire un graphique c'est de
faire un graphique en barres ce qui
permet du coup de pouvoir comparer
rapidement alors si vous allez si vous
voulez voir comment tout faire depuis
[Musique]
alors j'aimerais bien si je vais sur
cette analyse r si vous voulez voir
comment générer des différents tableaux
croisés les fusionner pour ensuite faire
un graphique complet à manuellement
vous pouvez voir l'exemple dont analysé
trajectoire de soins
un nom qui est le chapitre qui reprend
ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui
et si je vais dans la partie facteurs
associés à l'appartenance à chaque
groupe
vous vous y trouverez ici le un code qui
permet de faire en fait ce petit colza
en fait va permettre avec une boucle
forts qui sont des boucs sont répétés de
fusionner des événements ensemble pour
arriver à produire un tableau
entier qui va nous permettre de faire
directement ce type de graphique là sauf
que si on veut pas forcément son pt
alors on nous demande de rappeler le
lien du fichier pour rappel un si vous
allez sur le site des webinaires vous
avez le retour des différentes séances
pour qu'aujourd'hui on est sur la séance
numéro 20 qui est la suite directe de la
séance numéro trois si vous avez dans la
séance numéro 3 vous trouverez le
fichier et remarques down de la semaine
dernière et puis dans quelques jours je
déposerai dans le cadre de la séance
d'aujourd'hui un le fichier remarque
down qu'on aura atteint en fin de séance
donc pour ceux qui veulent faire un peu
plus de programmation qui veut voir un
exemple d'une boucle fort et comment on
peut fusionner pour faire soi-même avec
gégé pelote ce type de graphique là donc
je vous invite à les regarder sur le
site web binaire et vous y trouverez
notamment le principe des boucles fort
alors sur les bouquets fort on pouvait
trouver d'autres tutoriel sur internet
le principe c'est que vous avez or entre
parenthèses zeine quelque chose une
liste donc la ninja explanatory exploit
natori c'est un objet qu'on a créé juste
avant donc qui les animent ce beau sexe
âge éducation et puis entre crochets un
code qu'on va répéter donc le principe
c'est que je crée une variable vgt et
n'importe quel autre nom
j'indique in j'indique une liste de
valeurs et ensuite on va répéter ce code
là autant de fois qu'il y a de valeur
est la variable et va changer de valeur
tout au fur et à mesure donc j'ai ça
c'est vraiment souffler commence à faire
des choses un peu plus programmatique
mais on va voir qu'on peut obtenir le
même résultat
de manière tout aussi simple et facile
grâce au package et gally que nous
avions déjà vu et sa fonction gbe
variante on va charger gg galli en
mémoire
et on va
appel à gg vivarié donc le principe de
jal et des variétés ont valu pas
un jeu de données en amont alors je
donnais ce pas compliqué ans est le même
donc je vais reprendre large m18 groupe
h accès ducation est un label thx et je
vais y passer du coup j'ai dit bill
gates alors tenez là quand je veux des
place et du code pour l'indentation à
gauche ou à droite
la touche tab du clavier permet de
décaler vers la droite la couche et
shift tab décaler vers la gauche ça
permet du coup d'avoir des choses bien
alignés donc j'ai bien varié et on lui
passe un jeu de données je vais indiquer
quel est mon la haute comme donc la
variable d'autres comme ici ces groupes
quels sont les variables explicatives
donc je vais c'est le paramètre exple
anatolie je vais indiquer du coup c'est
des variables âge sexe et éducation du
coup en fait si je me trompe pas le cd
kiss in est même pas nécessaire et si je
fais ceci alors déjà j'ai
automatiquement un graphique qui se
présentent et voyez j'ai compte la
vallée wable explicatifs sont des
variables catégorielles on va avoir
directement un graphique ici en en barre
et ça me permet hélas j'ai directement
plus les pourcentages les pourcentages
en ligne et donc le gros avantage c'est
qu'en voyant un envoyé en sa on voit
très rapidement les variations d'un
groupe à l'autre donc là un voyez j'ai
la variable page et bien je vois que les
jeunes sont beaucoup plus souvent dans
le viol est que les plus âgés donc les
leurs soins alors que les l'étrange âge
supérieur vont avoir une tendance est
plus souvent dans les groupes rapide
lent
win aboutit donc à preuve il ya on voit
déjà ici à notre notre effet d'âge
concernant le sexe on voit que les
hommes sont aussi beaucoup plus nombreux
à être dans le groupe
or ce point que les femmes et quart
adverse les femmes sont plus nombreuses
et dans le groupe des rapides par
rapport aux hommes
et puis on voit également un effet du
niveau d'éducation puisque plus le
niveau d'éducation est faible plus la
probabilité d'être dans le fait d'être
dans la trajectoire hors soins va être
importante
autrement dit je conseille aux
différents groupes basse et sont un peu
structuré c'est à dire hiérarchiser
c'est à dire on a un groupe le meilleur
groupe ce sont les rapides le plus
mauvais ce sont les leurs soins
du coup que le la prise en charge pas
être meilleure pour les plus de 30 ans
les femmes et ceux qui ont un niveau
d'études supérieur
un autre élément que l'on peut utiliser
toujours en utilisant le package et
gally pour pour visualiser pour
visualiser en fait là où il ya des
effets en fait quels sont les que les
cases d'un tableau croisé qui sont sur
ou sous représentés c'est de passer par
les résidus du t2 pour rappel quand on
fait un test duty 2 1 si vous retournez
à vos cours de statistiques
hamon quand on fait un test duty 2 on va
calculer des effectifs théoriques qui
seraient les objets que les autres les
effectifs que l'on aurait observé si nos
deux variables étaient totalement
indépendante
ils ont comparé du coup nous observer
nos effectifs observé à à nos effectifs
théoriques et l'écart entre les deux
c'est ce qu'on appelle des résidus si
les effectifs observés sont supérieurs
aux effectifs théoriques c'est à dire
qui est une attraction dans cette case
du tableau si au contraire ils sont
négatifs c'est-à-dire que
ils sont sous représentées dans le dans
le tableau est donc le test dit qu'ils
reposent en fait sur ces écarts là
sachant que les résidus du kid 2 peuvent
être standardisé emporte tenir compte
des tags d'échantillons et auquel cas on
va avoir des résidus qui deux qui vont
et dans les résidus sont art disais on
considère qu'une cellule est
sur-représentée s'ils ont un résidu
supérieure à 2 ou 3 et qu'elle est
surreprésentée si le résident 8
inférieures à - 2 - 3 alors on peut
faire un tableau on peut représenter
sous forme graphique un tableau croisé
avec la fonction j'étais beau du package
égalise donc comme précédemment
on va les passer notre notre objet
l'argile 18e la bad
je vais appeler j'étais beau alors la
syntaxe un tout petit peu différente
c'est qu'on va déjà dire les colonnes en
x et des colonnes en y
on veut représenter donc on x donc à la
verticale je vais représenter la
variable je vais rester sur le même
format la variable groupe est en
je vais représenter mes trois variables
et à leur âge sexe et éducation une
petite différence qui entre gbe variété
j'étais bol c'est que j'ai blizzard y
est tu as forcément une seule variable
dans la hotte comme là où dont j'étais
beau l'on pourrait fournir plusieurs
arrêts allant mixer plusieurs variables
en y
si je fais pas je vais me faire exemple
supposons que j'ai représente aussi j'ai
fait à groupe essex par d
là on peut choisir du coup plusieurs
variables
il me va a peut être sur les deux côtés
donc là j'ai mis les vapes je vois
encore et après vous voir en ligne
voyez ça nous fait différents types de
tableaux croisés et par défaut ça nous
représentent les effectifs
je vais retirer sexe ans pour revenir un
tableau un peu plus simple on va pas je
veux juste montrer un coût pouvant
mettre plusieurs donc là j'aime être
juste groupon colonnes donc le gmi
différentes classes rapidement inaboutie
hors soins et en fait ça me redessine
les différents tableaux croisés si je
regarde l'aide de jets j'étais bon on a
différents paramètres dont le paramètre
sa hausse qui permet de dire qu'est ce
qu'on veut représenter dans les cellules
par défaut ce sont les ex les effectifs
observé d'accord mais on peut aussi
représenter alors pop qui est laid la
proportion du total
vos points les proportions en ligne call
propre les proportions en colonne bon
plus pourcentage expected les les
effectifs du des effectifs théoriques ou
les résidus du chi 2 essais des points
réside donc nous qui va nous intéresser
ici pour revenir au graphique on avait
juste avant ou sur le premier tableau
qu'on avait fait enquête et de
représenter les bosses entajan colonnes
1 pour voir comment chaque groupe se
représente différemment donc on peut
rajouter fleuve égale un col points
propres
si je
nous avons maintenant une représentation
des pourcentages en colonne à 1 donc je
vois que parmi les rapides ils sont 68%
à avoir entre 30 et 50 devant alors
qu'ils sont que 51% parmi les orcs soins
et ce qui va être intéressant ça va être
d'europe de colorer le tout est donc je
vais faire fil avec et steed y réside
donc les résidus du type 2 sont avisés
et en os
1 ceci juste pour que ça soit plus
lisible la légende n'est pas n'est pas
aboutie et donc il ya d'autres
paramètres qui viennent de gégé du coup
mais je vais juste rajouter les djeuns
et gains pour dire que je veux prendre
une légende qui vient du premier sous
graphique en fait ces trois graphiques
néant tu de l'autre ils sont représentés
voilà est donc ici vous voyez le code
couleur donc là vous avez en bleu les
résidus qui de qui sont positifs avec
ses étapes 2 et 3 en rouge les résidus
du qe2 qui sont négatifs et puis en
blanc entre -2 et deux là où il n'y a
pas d'effet l'intérêt des ré des résidus
qui 2 c'est que ça permet de voir
finalement quels sont les cellules 1 du
tableau qui vont s'écarter de
l'indépendance et celle qui joue
beaucoup
on voit par exemple son niveau éducation
a sexuellement lhenry n'aboutit joue peu
là où il ya des écarts c'est vraiment
sur le supérieur qui est sur représentée
dans le groupe des rapides alors que le
secondaire et le primaire sont
sous-représentées dans groupe des
rapides et averses dont le hors soins le
supérieur est sous représentée avec sept
cases rouges sur le sexe on voit pareil
que les enjeux se sont auto sur les
rapides donc dans la caste rapide les
femmes sont surreprésentées les hommes
surreprésentés on voit l' inverse femmes
sous représentés hommes sur représentés
dans leurs soins et on voit aussi que
dans les inaboutie les femmes souci un
petit peu plus sur représente l'intérêt
de ce type de représentations graphiques
et vous pouvez faire dans d'autres
analyses un pas forcément pourquoi zink
là ça peut être dans toute analyse
descriptive
c'est qu'elle réussit et qui dès lors
que vous avez beaucoup de variables nous
permet d'aller voir un peu plus
précisément quels sont les cases en fait
du tableau qui sont intéressantes qui
vont être pertinente à les commenter de
manière de manière plus fine
alors l'étape d'après là on a fait une
analyse qui est
nous avons fait du coup une analyse
univariée on a on a décrit une variable
catégorielles à quatre modalités par
rapport à d'autres variables ce serait
éventuellement d'aller faire une analyse
de facteurs par un modèle de régression
ce que nous avions abordé dans une
session précédente c'est le modèle le
plus courant qui est ce qu'on appelle la
régression logistique binaire et la
régression logistique binaire s'applique
dans le cas spécifique où l'on va avoir
une variable de type wii no 1 a vécu
l'événement n'a pas vécu l'événement là
il se trouve que notre outcome d'intérêt
ce sont ces différentes classes et donc
du coup on est sur une variable à plus
de deux modalités donc mais sur des
variables catégorielles et donc dans ce
cas là il faut utiliser une variante de
la régression logistique que l'on
appelle la régression logistique multi
nominé pour rappel ainsi et je reviens
sur le site analyse air dans le chapitre
consacré à la régression logistique
vous avez une sous partie dédiée à la
régression logistique multi nominale
sachez qu'il existe également ce qu'on
appelle une régulation logistique
ordinale la régression logistique
ordinale elle s'applique lorsque la
variable d'intérêt est clairement
structurée et ordonnée avec des valeurs
qui sont les nôtres sud et autres et du
coup on a une variante encore de la
régression logistique et on l'abordera
un petit peu plus tard là aujourd'hui on
va partir sur la régression logistique
multi inoni m alors ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que si la régression
logistique classique pouvaient être
réalisés directement avec les modèles
linéaires généralisée et avec la
fonction très générique glm 1 avec sami
l'igad binomiale sachant que les gels
elle paraît de faire aussi d'autres
types de régression dont les modèles de
poisson pour la régression du tina mian
il nous faut passer par une autre
extension et en l'occurrence ne faut pas
par la librairie est net qui propose une
fonction multi nomme pour faire un
modèle multi d'amiens
alors on va donc chargé est net et donc
pour réaliser notre analyse notre
variable d'intérêt doit être donc une
variable de type facteurs donc si je
regarde mon objet large m18 la variable
a expliqué qui nous intéresse est la
variable groupe là ce qu'on voit c'est
que le premier niveau c'est le niveau
rapide suivi du rapport laon puis
inaboutie puis hors soins est alors dans
quelle direction multi nominale de même
qu'il nous faut définir une référence
comme pour nos variables explicatives
il nous faut aussi définir une référence
pour la variable a expliqué et en fait
on va comparer chacun des groupes à la
première si je faisais mon modèle avec
le groupe telquel je comparerais un
l'élan aux rapides les inaboutie aux
rapides et leurs soins aux rapides
une alternative serait de dire je les
compare tous à une autre valeur de
référence par exemple j'aurais comparé
tout le monde par rapport à hors soins
pour ça il me faut donc du coup un
facteur ordonné un petit peu
différemment je vais donc faire
rapidement une nouvelle variable que je
vais appeler groupe 2 qui va être
égal à ma variable groupe mais je
ça changeait la boutique de référence
dont je fais un will va et ça on peut le
faire avec la fonction f c'était vrai la
ville de forks ou la fonction de base
air qui s'appelle juste oui les arts et
je vais indiquer hors soins comme ma
modalités de référence si je regarde la
variable que j'obtiens large m18 aux 2 1
c'est la même variable rapide long in
abouti et leurs soins qui a été déplacé
au tout début de 2 min faut pour faire
ma régression logistique
j'ai appelé reggane pour une régression
médina mian est bien j'appelle la
fonction multi nomme du package est net
et j'ai indiqué mon modèle est en fait
c'est comme l'indiqueraient mon modèle
pour une régression logistique classique
1 c j'invite la variable a expliqué aux
deux excusez moi un tilde et la liste
des variables explicatives
là en l'occurrence on va mettre sexe âge
et éducation et puis on
qui est le jeu de données dont tata
égale large et non 18
si je fais ça j'ai malgré tout avoir un
petit problème
n'oubliez pas des variables sexe âge et
éducation sont un moment qu des sous
forme numérique avec des étiquettes et
donc du coup si je l'aimais tel quel
dans le modèle
elles vont être prises en compte comme
des variables continue - alors c'est
variable là doivent être considérés
comme des variables comme des variables
catégorielles donc je n'oublie pas ici
d'appliquer un label globalement où
j'aurais pu faire une version ouvert des
transformations de l'est variable en
amont vous avez ici un petit résumé du
calcul du modèle le modèle à converger
sans trop de difficulté est donc
maintenant nous avons notre modèle multi
nominé pour voir à quoi il ressemble je
peux l'affiché éventuellement dans la
console ou faire plus haut un peu plus
avec un se marient de ride m
et donc ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
là on a du coup trois jeux de
coefficient 1 comme sur une régulation
musique classique vous avez un
intercepte le coefficient pour les
femmes pour chacune des catégories
mais vous l'avez dans la comparaison
rapide versus hors soins pour l'en
versus hors soins et dans inaboutie
versus pour soins pour visualiser tout
ça de manière peut-être un peu plus
facile et un peu plus un peu plus visuel
on va avoir directement recours je peux
faire déjà un passé ma régression à la
fonction tibial welsh du package qui
tissent mari
alors je me soignais puisque ça marche
pourquoi il me présente
ah oui alors ce qui se passe c'est que
ce que fais tu es belle owen wilson
il va vous présenter la série de
coefficient d'abord pour les rapides ton
par rapport à la double ipa par la
référence donc on présente d'abord
rapide versus hors soins vous avez une
1ère série coefficient puis il va vous
faire la même chose pour la 2eme
comparaison qui elle en versus hors
soins puis pour la troisème comparaison
qui est inaboutie versus hors soins ça
s'apprend pas mal de ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup ligne c'est vrai que c'est du
coup un peu plus dur à lien alors qu'ici
on voulait présenter dans un format
double vous avez aussi la fonction aux
ratios du package co actionnaire qui
peut être utilisée pour voir le
coefficient dans la console mais voyez
hein on retrouve la même chose c'était
que vous avez les coefficients pour
l'aller pour rapide puis les
coefficients pour laon puis décorez
fission pour une aboutit donc ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que dans une
régression logistique même si amiens on
va multiplier les coefficients parce que
les coefficients ouais tu fais pour
chacune des modalités de la variable
expliqué en comparaison de la modalité
de référence qui fait que ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup de coefficients et que
parfois c'est un peu dur de tout bien
visualiser
d'où l'intérêt de faire ce qu'on appelle
un fort et ce peloton c'est à dire un
graphique des coefficients et pour ça on
a vous avez on avait vu gg coeff modèle
du package et gally sauf que du coup il
ya une petite adaptation qui prévues
pour les modèles multi nommé haut et
d'en cas présent on va donc pas ces
règles
m à une variation qui s'appelle gg coeff
multi nomme dédié au modèle multi know
you
alors vous voyez quelques c
fait là les coefficients sont présentés
de manière brute donc comme ça modèle
multi nomia l'on voudrait plutôt voir
les zones ratio parce que c'est une
régression logistique dont j'ai indiqué
exponentielle des gardes fous et on va
pouvoir regarder un peu plus finement le
graphique que nous avons obtenu ce qui
se passait tout est représenté en même
temps donc on va pouvoir comparer un
petit peu mieux ce qu'on voit c'est que
que ce compte que l'on compare les
rapides au rejoint l'élan aux soins ou
les inaboutie o'war soins les femmes ont
systématiquement une probabilité plus
élevée que les hommes d'être dans les
catégories rapide lent ou inaboutie par
rapport aux hommes
on voit aussi de même un cet effet-là
sur le sur l'âge donc il n'ya pas de
semble-t-il de grosses grosses
différences quand on regarde les 30 59
aux 60 ans et plus par contre on voit
bien que à les 30 59 ans une probité
beaucoup plus élevés tête dans rapide
plus dans leurs soins ils ont aussi une
probité brésil dans l'enclos hors soins
mais voyez sans colle aux ratios encore
en dessous donc là vous avez tous les
autres assure présenté en même temps et
vous avez aussi une une représentation
alternative une des options qui est du
de ggf multi nomme c'est de vous
proposer un graphique non pas avec les
coefficients les en dessus des autres
mais de faire en fait trois facettes
pour représenter chacun des coefficients
et donc vous avez aussi une rampe en
version alternative de ce même graphique
qui est celui ci ça permet de mieux
séparer chacune des comparaisons mais du
coup on n'a plus la comparaison visuelle
des des coefficients 10 au dessus des
autres qui était pratique ce qui est à
retenir c'est que ce qui est compliqué
dans une régression logistique multi
damian l'un c'est que à chaque fois ci
je voulais savoir est ce que les
les 60 ans et plus ou une probabilité de
voir 30 59 ans une probabilité plus
élevée d'être dans les rapides que dans
l'en il faudrait faire le ratio de ces
deux coefficient donc là on voit bien
que que si je divise le coefficient des
rapides par celui du long j'obtiendrai
l'aude ratio au jour une chose de
positif mais c'est qu'on commence à
comparer beaucoup de choses ont beaucoup
de sens qui peut être parfois du coup
difficile de bien s'y retrouver
d'où l'intérêt à un moment donné si vous
avez peur de mal interpréter vos
coefficients et comment les ratios
s'explique les uns par rapport à les
autres de penser à regarder les effets
du modèle
je vous rappelle les effets du modèle ça
permet de recalculer les prédictions du
modèle pour chacune des variables à la
moyenne des autres variables et donc de
voir vraiment du coup les effets mais en
pour le coup dans le format de sortie
donc là on va le voir sous forme de
pourcentage ce qui est bien plus facile
à interpréter
donc si je veux le faire comme on
faisait pas régression logistique on va
pouvoir passer par la librairie dj efex
pour calculer tous les effets d'un
modèle
je vais appeler gg effect et je peux
directement lui appliquer mon modèle
alors si je fais ça ça me rend verra une
liste dé faire sous forme de tableau si
je veux du coup que mes effets soient
soit soit transformé du coup en
graphiques
je vais appliquer pelote à tout ça mais
auquel
voyez trois graphiques donc j'aurai
trois graphiques les uns après les
autres
un premier graphique qui est les effets
pour la variable sexe donc là on voit en
fait les prédictions du modèle toutes
choses étant égales par ailleurs on voit
que les femmes que l'écart entre en
reçoit les hommes ils sont beaucoup plus
que les femmes par contre que sur des
rapides ya un écart qui est marqué dans
les sommes sont bien bien plus souvent
non rapide que les hommes que sur lancer
un peu près équivalent et que sur
inaboutie ont fait ce qui se passe et
que les hommes sont tellement dans leurs
soins qui sait qu'ils sont peu plus bas
sur tout le reste
là vous avez les mêmes éléments par
rapport dont les prédictions du modèle
par rapport aux groupes d'âge et les
prédictions du modèle par rapport au
niveau d'éducation
l'intérêt c'est qu'ici c'est absolument
pas dépendants devant d'élite et de
référence ans est vraiment les
prédictions du modèle toutes choses
égales par ailleurs et on voit par
exemple là que la probabilité d'être
dans la trajectoire rapide augmente avec
le niveau d'éducation même si les
intervalles de confiance se superpose un
peu les uns aux autres si j'avais voulu
avoir tout ça sur un seul et même
graphique 1
il faut combiner plusieurs graphiques
ensemble elles combinent et des
graphiques cédant chapitre approfondir
combiner plusieurs graphiques on vous
présente plusieurs fonctions mais en
particulier la fonction plug quid du
package coop l'ofc et donc si je veut
l'appliquer ici je valais a pris la
fonction copilote pelote grid et il faut
que
je veux ça sur trois colonnes on va
vérifier
et là voyez j'ai un message d'erreur
alors deux éléments ce que fait bloc
quand je fais j'ai fait qu sur un modèle
ils me renvoyaient niolu liste des faits
et quand j'applique pelote à cette liste
des faits ça me renvoie une liste de
graphiques d'accord or comment
fonctionne qu'aux flottes claude creed
dont j'ai regardé l'aide copilote claude
bride en fait claude guidi s'attend à
voir un premier graphique plus virgules
un deuxième graphique virgules un
troisième trafic est pas une liste de
graphiques
ceci étant dit vous voyez ici un parent
ami qui s'appelle pote liste qui est
optionnelle et qui permet de fournir une
liste de graphiques
d'accord ce qui se passe c'est que quand
je fais mon pourcentage d'ailleurs
pourcentage s'applique malice de
graphiques non pas aux paramètres plate
liste 1 mais au premier paramètre qui
sont là quand je veux appliquer avec mon
pape un objet un argument particulier
est pas au premier argument je peux
utiliser un raccourci qui est points
donc là ça veut dire ce qui ce qu'il ya
avant parce le spécifiquement ici et
donc dû
il ya avant aux paramètres plaque liste
qui ce qui est attendu par la fonction
claude bride et en faisant ça j'obtiens
un graphique avec les trois trafics côte
à côte alors je vois qu'on graphique il
est peut-être c'est un peu dur à lire
peut-être qu'ils feraient que je
grandisse la taille du graphique et donc
si je fais un graphique je sais pas si
je vais lui pousse et si je fais 10
pouces sur 6 pouces
on sent graphique sur quelque chose de
plus grand du coup le texte va être
comparativement ou relativement la
taille du graphique du petit et j'aurais
probablement quelque chose de plus
lisible voyez
quand vous faites vos graphique 1 alors
là ça superposent encore un peu ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que les les graphiques
que vous avez que j'étais beau loup avec
gégé effect c'est des sondés graphique
qui permet d'avoir très rapidement
quelque chose de fonctionnel et
utilisable par contre voulait absolument
les refaire à la main là vous allez
passer beaucoup beaucoup de temps alors
nous avons vu là rapidement les c'est
vraiment une manière de vous présenter
rapidement ce qu'on peut faire une fois
qu'on a des catégories on peut du coup
allait réaliser une analyse de
régression logistique multi nauviale qui
est l'étape d'après pour regarder les
facteurs associés donc une des
possibilités d'une analyse de séquences
c'est d'aller faire fait d'aller faire
dans la foulée une analyse de facteurs
associés à à catégorie que vous avez
fait donc en fait les deux séquences
dans ce cas là et qu'une étape
analyse pour construire de nouvelles
variables qui va permettre d'aller
compléter vos éléments
sachant qu'on gagne aussi beaucoup de
choses avant de l'analyse de facteurs
simplement à bien décrire un peu
finement comme on l'a vu les différentes
étapes de l'analyse de séquences il
existe autre chose une autre approche
pour essayer de faire des catégories de
trajectoire alors c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué donc c'est vraiment là
juste une présentation très très
succincte
une des possibilités c'est ce qu'on
appelle les modèles mixtes à classe
l'attend alors ce type de modèle peut
prendre en compte une grande variété
d'indicateurs mais il faudra autres
comme soit soit continue donc numérique
soit binaire de type wii non 0,1 soit
ordinale en considérant du coup que on
peut le codé sous la forme 1 2 3 4 et on
peut intégrer dans ses modèles la déco
variable et surtout on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir le même nombre d'observations
par individu alors c'est des modèles qui
sont plus complexes donc là je sais plus
tôt pour vous mentionner leur existence
et si jamais un jour vous êtes
confrontés que ça vous intéresse vous
pouvez les voir ils sont implémentés
notamment soulac à librairie el cmm et
la fonction homonyme lcm l'idée assez
classe donc à présent notre variable de
statut dans les soins kate moss on va là
recoder sous une forme numérique et je
vais je la connais du coup sous la forme
un deux trois ou quatre ainsi on n'est
pas dans les soins 2 si on ne rit soins
n'est pas ce traitement
trois sonneries soins sous traitement et
4 si jamais on est
dans les soins sous traitement et
charges contrôlés en fait les ennemis
que ça casse latentes sont plus adaptées
si notre know tu comme qui la variable
qui évolué au cours du temps et est
variable d'une grandeur numérique par
exemple ça pourrait être une variable de
poids ou non une variable de wolf score
donc c'est plus adapté
6 qui évolué au cours du temps est une
variable numérique le désintérêt des des
modèles mis sa classe la tente c'est
qu'on est pas obligé d'avoir des
observations espaces et a même
intervalle dans le cas vous l'avez vu
dans le cadre mon de l'analyse de
séquences on a besoin de pas tant qu'ils
sont réguliers et on va observer des
choses à certains intervalles pour
recréer une séquence
l'idée c'est que dans un modèle mis sa
classe la tente en fait la trajectoire
d'un individu elle peut se présenter
sous la forme d'une courbe qui évolué au
cours du temps et on a plus ou moins un
point pour décrire l'évolution de cette
grandeur quantitative avec le temps en x
et la valade qui nous intéresse on y
donc là par exemple un exemple de classe
l'attend c'est de se dire que donc le
temps long nous avons des patrons qui
sont réguliers on assez variable moi je
vais transformer mariable de soins en
une variable continu qui pourrait valeur
un deux trois ou quatre et je peux
appeler la variable elle s'est elle même
pour faire un modèle
donc l'idée cyclage avaient modélisé
d'accord ma vie mon statut dans les
soins médicaux des manières numérique en
fonction du mois il faut que j'indique
linkers fraîches ou chaudes pour
préciser que les lava que la variable
qui représentait son format de tracas en
fait c'est une
faites une variable ordinale parce que
ça va permettre de prendre ça en compte
il faut indiquer du coup le mois sur les
paramètres d'hommes et mecs chelsea
voulait des choses plus compliquées il
faut aller voir l'aide de de ses modèles
là et puis on va indiquer le
l'identifiant voyez les données que je
vais donner à lcm est mince et une ligne
pars pars pas de temps c'est une ligne
par pat temps qui est utilisé dans ce
modèle à long et à un format large
si vous lancez ce mode de calcul là ça
va prendre beaucoup de temps ça prend
plusieurs heures sur votre ordinateur si
vous voulez récupérer les résultats vous
avez le code ici pour récupérer
directement le résultat mais c'est des
types de modèles qui sont très longs
autre élément j'ai dû indiquer dès le
début le nombre de catégories de je
voulais donc là je vais indiquer que je
veux quatre catégories
comment ça se passe une fois que le
modèle effet il va alors dans les
résumés du modèle on va récupérer un à
hisser est un pays c'est donc au jeu
pour essayer de faire un modèle avec
deux catégories un autre avec trois un
autre avec 4 un autre avec cinq épis
regarder celui qui aurait le meilleur le
plus petit est ici le plus petit billet
pour faire une sélection
c'est une possibilité faut juste être
patient parce que c'est très long à
calculer mais ce que va faire le modèle
c'est que là j'ai indiqué jouer quatre
classes et pour chaque individu
j'ai dans une colonie s'appelle paix
prob d'accord qui va nous dire je pars
en bleu premier indivise sans le dire
qu'il a on à la probabilité
d'appartenance à chacune des quatre cas
ce que j'ai défini donc cet individu
aurait 17 % de chance tu es dans la
tasse une 0 2% dans la classe de 0 2%
dans la classe 3 et 41% d'appartenir à
la classe 4 est donc cet individu avait
classé dans la classe 4 puisque ça la
classe woods a plus de chances d'être
d'appartenir
l'intérêt ici un je vous le dis c'est
que ce type de modèle arrive à ajuster
son fait qu'on a des points on n'a pas
forcément le même nombre de points
d'observation pour tous les individus
plus certains ont observé que deux mois
que d'autres vont être observés 18 mois
d'autres 30 mois donc on n'a pas de
problème avec ce type de modèle à
ajuster du coût des temps d'observation
différent ici j'ai fait mon modèle
surtout les individus du fichier pas
comme sur l'analyse de séquences où
j'avais pris en compte qu'une partie des
individus et donc c'est une autre
manière de récupérer une classe un nom
j'ai avoir quatre classes et donc je
peux récupérer du coup inde en mode 4
donc le nom du modèle de l'app et
épreuve samedi pour chaque individu son
identifiant la classe ou d'attribuer et
sa propre style à part tant sa chacune
des classes
on peut du coup récupérer on peut
récupérer du cou à cette classe là un et
on va pouvoir du coup comme précédemment
faire des comparaisons alors si vous
regardez ici je vous représente al ça
c'est le les graphiques on est au tout
début inquiéter la répartition c'est pas
des tapis de c'est comme en france et
bien la répartition dans les sons à
chaque étape
alors sachant que les individus qui ont
fait observer que trois mois d'autres
six mois les voiliers en fait les
classes qui émerge ici une place très
rapide 1 et puis une case un peu moins
lent une classe de gens qui va quand
même démarré ressortir puis revenir et
ici vous avez une classe de gens qui
vont être beaucoup de temps donc on
reste toujours un peu sur cette idée un
voyez nous donner nous renvoie toujours
un peu vers quelque chose de rapide et
de nom même si l'on n'a pas vraiment une
casse or joint qui émergent en tant que
tel une manière alternative de
représenter tout ça c'est de se dire que
comme on l'a dit que c'était un score
allant de la a4 je peux calculer le
score moyen
à chaque pas de temps ça ça peut se
faire à la volée avec gégé galli en y
ont recours à la statistique wait is
mine
1 donc en fait où là je faire graphique
qu'on nie que ce genre présente le mois
en crec mon statut
j'indique est couleur et en faisant
statique white is mine ça va calculer la
valeur moyenne à chaque pas de vie
grecque
ce qui va me permettre de représenter
ceux ci c'est un peu la position moyenne
de la classe à chaque pas de temps donc
on voit une position moyenne avec l'idée
que représente diagnostic et de suivi
trois sous traitement 4control et on a
fait une moyenne de toutes ces valeurs
donc c'est pas tout à fait aussi c'est
une relation très synthétique mais on
voit bien qu'on est une classe de très
rapide la classe deux quines case qui va
évoluer pour grey sivement une de l'an
épicé classe 3 qui était un peu atypique
c'est son décès une classe où ça va
d'abord monté puis ça va redescendre
oui c'est une sorte de deux ou deux
classes qui va capturer un peu des
sorties de soins après il faut rester
vigilants là ce que je vous présente ici
un c'est une reconversion très
synthétique qui peut masquer en fait la
diversité des trajectoires sur jacentes
notamment table de jerry d'enchaînement
des événements et c'est pour ça que dans
tous les cas il vaut mieux aller faire
des tapis de séquences donc là je vous
ai refait on l'avait vu la semaine
dernière avec gégé pelote un graphique
de tapis de séquences mais cette fois ci
alors j'ai dû trier sur la durée à des
différentes castes oui on a les quatre 4
présenté différemment et donc
sassus une qui à 844 observations qui
est celle ci ou ça va très vite
alors oui on mélange des gens qui sont
servait peu de temps des gens qui sont
observés le très longtemps mais une
classe très rapidement à haut rendement
les soins donc on retrouve bien notre
idée de deux rapides on a la classe iv
qui à la place qui est très lente
en fait on voit que ça augmente la
situation sur le long terme parce qu'en
fait il ya tous les gens qui sont pas
rentrés en soit au début
et ces gens là ne contribue plus sur les
niveaux élevés 1 comme tout à l'heure on
a des gens avec des formations courtes
et longues et donc si on regarde sur la
durée et bien effectivement certains
m'ont quand même rentré en soins on a du
coup ceux qui vont progresser plus
longtemps de manière intermédiaire c'est
la classe 2 a envoyé une petite classe
qui représentez ici
et puis enfin on assez classe iii où on
sent qu'il ya des ressorti de soins
inquirer émergent qui rénergie ci avec
des choses un peu intermédiaire oui si
on a des gens qui sont bien entrés en
soins
mais au lieu d'être cassée dans la hune
vont passer dans la chaste encore une
fois ce qui va compter pour savoir
quelle est la meilleure méthode
appliquée à vos données sait vraiment
comment vous vous posez la question est
ce que j'ai envie de dire
alors que d'autres d'autres vous diront
qu'il ya plein de raisons statistiques
de choisy plus tôt une classe plutôt
qu'une autre côté plutôt quelque chose
moi ce qui me semble important c'est
vraiment de considérer qu'elle est la
classe qui va faire le plus de 100 g
point de vue sociologique et qui avoue
pleurer donner du sens à vos données
donc je suis pas un statisticien je suis
vraiment un utilisateur de statistiques
est donc abandonné août les comptines
ces rations purement technique et
méthodologique à voir se dire qu'est ce
qui fait sens ou qu'elle ait l'âme la
méthode qui en terme de philosophie est
plus proche de la manière dont je
consomme un objet voilà donc ce que je
voulais vous présenter
non c'était ce type
sachez que ça existe le jour vous en
aurez besoin
vous irez creuser du côté du package cmm
donc je vous retrouve il est là dès
qu'on veut plus d'informations dont va
faire cran lc mm pour savoir la
documentation de ce package et notamment
voyez vous avez une introduction aux
principes et la tante process et et une
autres vignettes qui vous qui vous donne
plus de background alors ça c'est en
anglais mais qui va donner plusieurs
grandes là dessus ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'ils ont des intérêts du package
et c est même mais pareil on arrive sur
des choses plus compliquées
c'est qu'on peut aussi introduire dans
le calcul des des classes des vars et
des cofacteurs par exemple j'aurais pu
mettre l'âge et le sexe comme cofacteur
et donc du coup avoir une modélisation
qui va tenir compte en fait je de
rajouter en fait la demande du coup des
cofacteurs qui vont jouer alors c'est
plutôt intéressant simeco facteurs sont
des variables qui sont dépendantes du
temps mais ça voudrait dire que ça peut
permettre en fait de douala d'ordre des
modélisations plus complexes de
trajectoire
ceci étant je vous recommande vraiment
de pas trop aborder ces modèles mixa
classe attendent donc vous ai pas le
temps de mieux vous familiariser avec
des techniques classiques est vraiment
de vous demander si ça peut importer un
intérêt par rapport à votre type de
données encore une fois il faut être
vigilant parce que trop de complexité
statistiques ne viennent pas masqué
l'intérêt
l'intérêt de votre de votre analyse
voilà je vous propose de s'arrêter là
pour aujourd'hui d'une part parce que je
sais que des séances de deux heures ça
fait beaucoup trop c'est comme ça
devient difficile de se concentrer donc
je vous propose d'être quelque chose
d'un peu plus concis là on est plutôt
sur on va montrer des techniques qui
sont éventuellement existantes
la semaine prochaine on apportera la fin
de cette partie là avec un premier
exemple de modèles observations répétées
histoire de cirque avait un petit modèle
à un petit modèle j'ai eu avant de vous
quitter juste pour vous présenter ça et
puis rapidement aussi un modèle de
survie multi est assez juste pour vous
je dirai juste survolé vous montrer
l'existence de certaines méthodologies
certaines méthodes et de comment elle
existe dans des aires histoire de vous
ouvrir un peu l'esprit avant avant l'été
puisqu'on va forcément les webinaires
vont s'arrêter pour pendant la période
estivale
et puis je sais pas encore exactement
les formes qu'ils vont prendre à la
rentrée ce qui est certain c'est que je
pourrais pas maintenir des webinaires
toutes les semaines ce qui
m'intéresserait c'est de pouvoir aborder
peut-être un webinaire tous les mois ou
tous les deux mois sur un sujet qui me
qui me qui me fait envie qui me
permettrait aussi d'avoir un peu de
temps pourrait s'y développer des
contenus additionnels sur un analyseur
puisque cette année je me suis
concentrée essentiellement sur des
contenus qui étaient déjà présents
quoi qu'il en soit je vous souhaite une
très bonne fin de journée bonne
réalisation replay pour ceux qui ne sont
pas présents et on se retrouve du coup
pour un prochain webinaire pour
finaliser nos différentes approches
statistiques sur cet exemple de
trajectoire de soins merci pour tous et
à très bientôt